uh our guest today steve murphy he is
the man who took down pablo escobar if
you want to bring that picture up
with pablo and uh he wrote a book he and
javier pena which we've had on before
the last time he was on the title of the
interview i think we did was who killed
pablo escobar
it was a title got a few million views
three million views to be exact that's
himself right there that's pablo
this event happened when that picture is
what 93 december 2nd 93 december 2nd 93
from then till today uh i mean you took
down you wrote a book about how you guys
took down pablo escobar
after that from that moment till today
how much have you seen changed from
the the world or different countries
popping out the next pablo escobar
is there possibilities of having the
next pablo escobar since you guys took
down pablo
absolutely you know and and so on our
speaking tours we open up for q and a
with audiences
you can ask us anything i mean you can
talk us about the investigation you
asked about the netflix series narcos
we'll talk about our personal lives to a
certain degree
but one of the most frequently asked
questions is how
has drug trafficking or the war on drugs
changed since the death of pablo escobar
the world's first narco-terrorist
the world's most wanted criminal of his
day
well but the first answer is can you
still go out on any street core in the
united states about cocaine
we all know the truth you can it hasn't
diminished at all
you look at the prices the supply versus
demand prices are down the wholesale
prices of cocaine in the united states
coming into the united states are down
which is indicative of a large supply of
cocaine coming in
the sad thing is here in the united
states we are the leading consumer
country in the world when it comes to
illegal narcotics
that's a reputation we're not proud of
but it's the truth
so people say well why have a drug war
on drugs you know we're looking at
legalization of marijuana as well as
other drugs out here in the united
states
so this is a lot of people think it's
strange coming from javier now when we
say this
the war on drugs is one of the biggest
misnomers i've ever heard
go back to the time of pablo escobar
we're going after a person who's
responsible for 80 percent
of the cocaine supply in the world wow
now think about this and your
occupations wouldn't you like to have 80
of the markets it's called a monopoly
yes right and that's what he was able to
achieve
so we're going in on this war on drugs
well when you go to the war
you get your allies together you get
your material your personnel
you go in to win what do we do in
colombia
we sent two americans i have your
opinion steve murphy does that sound
like a war
now we had support from the embassy we
had agents just chomping at the bit to
come and join us up there
we had dea offices all around the world
you had law enforcement around the world
wanting to participate and assist
any way they possibly could but it was
not a war
you know it seemed like it because of
all the bombings we're flying in on huey
gunships being shot at as we're coming
in
you're going out on patrols and having
car bombs blow up and kill police
officers that you're traveling with
you've got indiscriminate car bombs
going uh going off around all the cities
bogota medellin and cali
simply because pablo escobar wanted to
impose his will on everybody else
to make him he wanted you know he got
elected as a member of congress
the justice minister rodrigo lavinia had
the stones to stand up and call him what
he was a murderer and a drug trafficker
we know what happened to him exactly it
cost him his life he played the ultimate
price but you know what the man is a
hero
because he was brave enough to stand up
and tell the truth
well you know maybe if we could do that
here in the united states stand up and
tell the truth yeah
you know not anyway pat can i make one
quick yeah shaman on this photo the
first time i've seen this photo steve
just looking at you the thing that just
jumps out at me
you look relieved like so much of your
life had been spent obsessing about this
guy
and maybe you couldn't even believe it
at that time that he's lying in front of
you dead
i mean was it an obsession was that all
that you were consumed with and how long
did it take how long were you after him
well so i wrote this
this picture is the combination of an
18-month manhunt but pablo escobar
started dealing drugs in the late 70s
early 80s so this was a long time this
is december 1993.
there were two manhunts the first one
before his surrender which he got the
you know the deal of a lifetime where he
surrendered to his custom-built prison
staying there one year and then the day
he country club i mean he built his
prison i mean who gets to build their
own prison it's ridiculous yeah
and you go in there and he had a
two-room suite he had a jacuzzi tub in
his private bathroom
you know what we have in the united
states just like everywhere else is
group showers
that's right i mean it's just it's
ridiculous but
you're right in the fact that we felt
like the weight of the world had been
lifted off our shoulders my wife
and i had adopted our first daughter we
have two sons that were back in the
united states
it's and i tell people a lot of people
read the book or they see the different
shows and
interviews that we've done and they'll
email us they'll send us messages hey
i'm interested in becoming a de agent
what's it all about
first thing i tell them it's not a job
it's a lifestyle it will affect
every area of your life and you know
what happens
and this is wrong i don't believe in
this i believe i believe our priority
should be god
family job what happens though
your priorities become job family
god okay so that it just becomes
concerning
unfortunately that's not the way it's
supposed to be why is that why do you
say god last
just because you get consumed by things
like this every sin in the bible you
have to commit
is that kind of why you're saying god
goes last because to really pull off
what you want to do
you're going to have to do stuff that
god wouldn't be is that what you're
saying or no you don't lose your values
and principles no
never okay you never give up yourself
why would god go last though
it's just the way it happens you know
because you're you're consumed by things
like this
i mean i'm living in medellin for 18
months my wife's back in bogota we
adopted our first daughter
so she's back there i can't even spend
time with them javier's family's back in
texas they can't
he can't come and visit his family
because they wanted us both in country
you know every day to handle what was
going on and then when you do get to
come home and see your family
you're kind of focused on them and
that's where they come in second
and then with your principal i grew up a
preacher's kid you know
so god's very uh strong part of our
family of our beliefs um thank god he's
a merciful god and
and uh forgiving because i had a lot to
be forgiven though
but the thing is we never broke the law
we broke policies and procedures
every day we weren't supposed to go out
on operations we're flying down on
operations every day in helicopter
gunships going on raids you never
broke the law you broke policies and
procedures every day oh they didn't want
us to leave the base the first policy we
broke was leaving the base
bend the rules a little bit right no we
broke it
[Laughter]
you know we had we had the us army's
delta force we had the
seal team six from the u.s navy with us
for 18 months and guys i gotta tell you
those are the studs of the world
i don't hold a candle to them but
they're military they obey
the rules the orders the policies and
procedures you don't have to
well we're supposed to um but we knew we
couldn't do their job and think about
this
tom think about this what if i said hey
listen i heard pablo escobar's down at
the corner first in maine go see if he's
down there i'm gonna get a cup of coffee
come back let me find out tell me what
you found out can i take a blackhawk to
go look
no but i think how much respect would
you have for me
right how rich was he how i mean
you know we talked about this but how
rich was he
well if you know there's a lot of uh
speculation out there that uh
okay in his in his day and time he was
the richest criminal in the world
go do the research now find out who the
richest criminal has been of all time
he's still number one his his uh
estimated wealth is as high as 33
billion
i read an article here just recently
where it's estimated to be at 33 billion
dollars
forbes magazine came out seven years in
a row raking
rickingham is the seventh richest man in
the world now i don't know how they came
up their statistics makes you
a little suspicious about that number
right but
you know people say well what about el
chapo not even close not he's i mean
he's a billionaire he's a
multi-billionaire
but not even close to what pablo escobar
was able to amass
and i don't i'm coming across i feel
like i'm coming across excitedly saying
this
this is not a good thing you know none
of his money was earned from legal
pursuits
all of his money was blood money all of
his
money was blood money today who is the
modern-day pablo
would it be an el chapo well it's just
it's his successor
a guy who's been around for years who's
a very well-known mexican
ishmael zambada they call him amayo
so when chapa moved up to the united
states to serve the rest of his life in
one of our prisons
myo has taken over his position as a the
head of the sinaloa cartel yeah
and ishmael zambot has been around for
years and years he's not a newbie
here's here's the difference though
these guys were pop culture icons
right i mean pablo escobar el chapo you
never heard of this guy
are they being less glamorized now or
are we going to find out more about him
oh you're going to find out more
he's just is he says first of all
you understand how violent choppa was i
mean we've all read the articles and
seen reports and i've probably seen
things that you haven't had access to
zimbada would not have gotten in that
position if he couldn't carry on
you know he's got to mean he's got to
forcefully maintain his
position of leadership which is true in
the dark drug world
you know people say we took out pablo
escobar it had zero effect well that's
because there's so much money involved
and there's so many people in this world
that are waiting to take advantage of
you
and you and me because if it's
if it's drugs okay if it's weapons if
it's counterfeit clothing
whatever the case might be they're
criminals you know and that's what they
know
there's no remorse no guilt feelings in
their actions
you